حان الوقت لحظر الحرس الثوري الايراني
ندوه تحت قبه البرلمان البريطاني تضع
حكومه ريشيسوناك تحت ضغط كبير لادراج هذه
القوه العسكريه لمهيمنه التابعه للمرشد
الاعلى للثوره الاسلاميه في ايران على
قوائم الارهاب بعد الكشف عن مزيد من
الاعمال الارهابيه التي يتورط فيها
الاعتبار الاكثر اهميه هو الانشطه الشائنه
الخبيثه التي يقوم بها الحرس الثوري ليس
في ايران فقط وانما في المملكه المتحده
ايضا ومن الممكن ان تشكل تهديدا للولايات
المتحده
الندوه التي نظمها المجلس الوطني للمقاومه
الايرانيه كشفت عن تفاصيل وثيقه حصلت
عليها المعارضه من الدخل الايراني لاجتماع
لمكتب المرشدي علي خامنئي برئاسه محسن
قومي واحد المشاركين في فيلق القدس التابع
للحرس الثوري لتنسيق مع وزاره الخارجيه
واجهزه النظ لاحضار خمسه وخمسين شخصا من
فنزويلا العام الماضي وتوضح الوثيقه مدى
تدخل هذه القوه في هذا البلد كما تحدد
الوثيقه بوضوح كيف ان اجهزه النظام مثل
جمعيه المصطفى واهل البيت هي دعايه دينيه
في خدمه في فرق القدس الى جانب دور وزاره
الخارجيه والسفارات كواجهات للانشطه
الاصوليه والارهابيه لنظام الايراني
سنستمر في هذا الضغط لانه من الواضح تماما
ان تلك القوات المسلحه هي قوه ارهابيه
وانا متاكد من ان الحكومه البريطانيه ليس
لديها شك في هذا الامر انه قرار سياسي
وكما يعد النائب بلاكمن فان النواب
سيستمرون في هذا الضغط على وزيري الخارجيه
والداخليه وانا متاكد من اننا سنصل الى
هدفنا
وسبق لرئيس جهاز المخابرات الداخليه
البريطانيه
وخطف ما لا يقل عن عش المقيمين على
الاراضي البريطانيه تتهمهم بانهم اعداء
النظام
لم تتخذ الحكومه البريطانيه قرارا بعد
بشان حظر الحرس الثوري الايراني فيما تدرس
تقريرا مفصلا في هذا الخصوص لكن يبدو انها
تمضي في هذا الاتجاه بالتنسيق مع الحلفاء
كما تشير بعض التقارير الاعلاميه مصطفى
زاروه العربيه لندن